[Musique]
quand la vie vous donne des citrons fait
de la citronnade ce proverbe rappelle
que dans l'adversité
nous avons toujours su innover et créa
mais ce que nous avons et la vie nous a
donné de l'eau et en retour
l'oms a donné la vie avec ça nous avons
appris à faire beaucoup plus que la
citronnade mais nous manquons désormais
d'eau et padoue pas de citronnade nous
faisons face à une crise mondiale de
l'eau mais aujourd'hui je veux que nous
voyons en simple
c'est une prise à quai nous avons des
solutions en 2020 le forum économique
mondial a classé la crise mondiale de
l'eau comme l'un des dix plus grands
risques pour l'humanité
l'estimant avec un impact plus important
que la propagation d'une maladie
infectieuse est plus probable qu'une
crise financière
c'est une ressource si vital que l'ol
lui a consacré l'accès à l'eau comme un
droit fondamental
nous n'avons pas de substituts pour
l'eau chacun de nous mourrions en
quelques jours seulement centrale
l'économie s'arrêterait même les sites
run vous serez plus ainsi depuis des
millénaires
notre prospérité dépend de la confiance
que nous pourrons avoir de l'eau de mer
nous vivons sur la planète bleue et 70 %
de sa surface est recouverte d'eau mélo
tout ce dont nos vies dépendent
légèrement beauty 97 % de l'eau sur la
surface du globe et de l'autre salle 2 %
constitue la banquise et ne nous reste
que 1% de nous présente si on passe du
globe sous la forme d'eau douce liquide
dont plus de deux tiers sont sous terre
est difficile à accéder il nous est donc
une quantité d'eau qui tiendrait dans
une sphère de la taille de l'inde pour
boire se laver faire pousser de notre
nourriture les ressources pour nos
habitations alors et nous nous sommes
donc développé grâce à l'utilisation de
l'eau présente en surface
c'est le cas de toutes les grandes
villes de france présentent au tour de
fleuve avec la maîtrise de nos
ressources
date limite et nous sommes développer
considérablement au début du dernier
siècle après des décennies d'innovations
dans les infrastructures et
l'assainissement
nous avons réalisé une prouesse nous
avons commencé à installer lecointe on
ouvre à un robinet et hop de l'eau
propre
sept personnes sur dix ont de l'eau qui
coule directement chez eux mais ça c'est
si nous regardons le verre à moitié
plein car si nous regardons le dr à
moitié vide trois personnes sur
non pas cette chance et ce verre à
moitié vide pourra devenir complètement
nous n'avons pas achevé ses prouesses en
gestion nous nous lavons initiée il ya
plus de 100 ans et encore plus de 2
milliards de personnes en sont privés 2
milliards
c'est difficile de se représenter le
nombre de vies histoire que ça pourra
voter pour celui imaginé un milliard de
dhs
c'est 32 ans si nous pouvions regarder
dans les yeux c'est 100 milliards
d'histoire 10 par an ne serait ce qu'une
seconde chacune il nous faudrait toute
une vie pour voir les leurs défilés 800
millions de personnes n'ont même pas
accès à l'eau potable
imaginez toute la pollution de l'union
européenne et des états unis sans accès
à ce besoin basique
ainsi en 2015 l'onu a établi que l'accès
à l'eau et à l'assainissement comme l'un
des dix sept objectifs de développement
durable
ces objectifs représentent les défis les
plus importants de notre société avec la
lutte contre la faim la lutte contre la
pauvreté l'accès à l'éducation ou encore
l'égalité entre les sexes établir une
eau propre et l'assainissement pour à
tous est ainsi autant l'un des plus
grands défis mais aussi l'une des
solutions améliorer son accès est ainsi
un levier pour améliorer la santé
l'éducation l'égalité non développement
de ces milliards d'histoire car les
maladies liées à l'eau sont aujourd'hui
l'une des plus grandes causes de
mortalité infantile dans le monde selon
l'oms la diarrhée tue plus de cinq cent
mille enfants de moins de cinq ans tous
les ans un enfant meurt chaque minute
d'une maladie que l'on sait prévenir et
traiter un monde reboul c'est aussi une
cause de malnutrition à déshydratation
avait des conséquences à long terme sur
la santé et l'égalité des chances de ses
enfants un enfant malade devant marché
plusieurs heures pour trouver l'eau est
un enfant qui n'est pas l'école et les
femmes sont particulièrement touchés par
sa conséquence parce qu'elles sont
souvent responsables famille d'aller
costello c'est plus de 200 millions
d'heures par jour qui sont dédiés à
cette activité au sein d'un comité
international 100 content des heures
précieuses pour développer d'autres
activités et pendant lesquels nous fit
s'éloigne et l'école on estime que
chaque euro investi dans l'eau et
l'assainissement font dire à un retour
économique quatre fois plus important
avec des coûts de santé - l'augmentation
de la productivité
la diminution des morts prématurées ce
sont 250 milliards d'euros qui seraient
sauvées chaque année
tout cela est aussi possible en
développant drôme était une de
filtration
plus adapté toutes les idées possibles
sont nécessaires pour lutter contre
cette crise mondiale car nous avons tort
de penser que c'est une crise dans
laquelle il y a eu et 1
il n'y a pas de peu car ce fardeau va
bientôt se trouver sur toutes nos
épaules sept personnes sur dix ont accès
à l'eau chez eux et ceux vers commencent
à se guider et ça pourrait ne plus être
le cas
nous étions 1,6 milliard en 1900 nous
sommes aujourd'hui 7 8 milliards et
chaque année 80 millions de personnes
supplémentaires d'agrandir notre société
mais avec notre petit pourcent de
disponibles dgac ne sont pas bons en un
siècle
notre consommation d'eau a été multiplié
par sept et nous avons dépassé les
quantités d'eau disponibles en surface
nous sommes donc devenus meilleurs à
atteindre les eaux souterraines dans ce
qu'on appelle les acquis l'air mais ces
acquis fermé des millénaires à se
remplir ce sont donc comptés tarbes et
là nous vivons à crédit
selon l'institut mondial des ressources
entre 3 et 5 milliards de personnes
pourrait manquer d'eau d'ici cinq ans de
nombreuses grandes villes à travers le
monde se prépare à cette situation dans
cette décennie
mexico melbourne pékin tokyo londres ou
encore parce le être conscient de cette
situation a de l'usaj que nous faisons
de l'eau est alors la première étape
pour trouver des solutions
nous connaissons déjà notre consommation
et olivier delaitre par jour pour boire
3 litres pour se laver les mains
cinquante pots douche cette consommation
associée aux droits fondamentaux déclaré
par l'onu comporte 10 % de la
consommation d'eau mondiale la part du
lion revient à l'agriculture qui
comptent pour 70 % de notre consommation
d'eau mondiale ce sont les 2500 litres
d'euros nécessaires pour faire pousser
le coton pour un seul t-shirt ou pour
faire un kilo de lentilles l'agriculture
a besoin d'eau et nous avons une
communauté de presque 8 milliards de
personnes à nourrir 8 milliards plus les
50 milliards d'animaux d'élevage qui
nous mangeons chaque année en même temps
une vague consommé 12 kg fourrage par
jour et faire pousser un cloud ce
fourrage nécessite 500 lignes d'eau au
final ce sont 15 ml d'eau qui seront
nécessaires pour avoir un kilo peuvent
la majeure partie de notre source c'est
vital et un subtilisé par l'éleveur
le défi de l'eau et donc la compacte
chèvre ou plus dans l'assiette que dans
le m car de besoin de nourriture qu'on
s'accroître l'unesco a estimé que le
site 2050
nos besoins en nourriture augmenté de
70% ainsi en étant le premier lecteur du
manque d'eau l'agriculture et l'élevage
sont aussi l'une des premières solutions
le reste de notre consommation d'eau
utilisée pour l'industrie la
construction par exemple est un secteur
très gourmande et avec l'augmentation de
la population
nous allons bâtir l'équivalent de new
york tous les mois pendant les quarante
prochaines années
ce sont là aussi des défis pour nos
ressources que nous pouvons surmonter
avec des innovations dans les procédés
dans les matériaux ou encore dans le
disait de nos espaces de vie pour avoir
des choix par défaut plus économes nous
ne voyons pas la consommation en eau nos
activités car nous ne payons pas pour
une paix non seulement pour les
infrastructures qui permettent de
l'année jusqu'à des robinets et sans
signal sur la valeur économique de cette
ressource si précieuse
aucun individu entreprises industries au
gouvernement notre raison d'un risque de
fuite
mais avec sa réflexion c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler sa valeur sans
égal grâce à des innovations dans
l'hôtellerie suite la réutilisation de
l'eau ou la prévenance de la pollution
nous pouvons nous assurer que nous avons
toujours de la nôtre heures nos
assiettes et de l'eau dans les robinets
c'est une nécessité car c'est autant la
bonne chose à faire que la chose
intelligente à faire
je suis optimiste pour le futur ce chat
est à portée de main la portée des
dogues
c'est vrai nous avons besoin 2010 et
d'innovation mais nécessité est mère
d'un mission parce que l'amélioration de
l'accès à l'eau améliore la santé
globale l'axé l'éducation l'accès à la
nourriture dans des pays initiation des
ressources pour la construction le
transport énergie tant d'autres ce sont
autant de chinon indispensable pour que
les communautés continuent de s'élever
la vie nous a donné l'eau alors
continuons d'en faire bien plus que la
citronnade